[Music]
you guys this has been a crazy week in
america let's find out what happened
more than 70 mcdonald's restaurants in
california this week began
offering free coronavirus vaccines to
the public
but don't bother trying to get it the
vaccine machine is broken
while conceding the new york city
mayoral race on tuesday
candidate andrew yang said quote there
was so much about new york city
i did not know said the person he was
talking to
this is newark the big snapple
if i can make it here i've made a thing
no that's not how it goes
according to newport
[Laughter]
newport newport no no
he doesn't know what he was running for
according to new reports the nypd is
expected to
to exceed its overtime budget for the
year by over 160 million dollars
damn if they keep that up those police
are going to defund themselves
according to the new york times a lab
recently analyzed the tuna
from several subway tuna sandwiches and
found that they contained
absolutely no tuna at all that's true
the news has created
a scandal first no that's not a scandal
who was that it was me mike hamilton
i represent subway this isn't a scandal
thank you
wait wait wait what was that that didn't
address anything
what about the tuna what about it is it
tuna
i don't know well that's bad you can't
sell something called tuna and then
not have it be tuna that's a scandal no
it's not
then what is it that's a thing that
happened
aren't you ashamed look i work at subway
it's a successful sandwich company
with franchises all over the world it
makes billions of dollars every year
and guess what nobody likes it not one
person
most people are fine with it they
tolerate it but no one enjoys it
is our food rotten no is it good
no way is it tuna
who cares it doesn't matter you know why
because you're at subway if you find
yourself in a situation where subway is
your only available option
you're still gonna get subway and if the
sandwich artist says
we only have tuna guess what what
you're gonna get that tuna wow you're
very honest
that's why subway hired me as their
spokesperson apparently the last guy
wasn't very honest and it caused a few
problems oh
right that guy now that
was a scandal he told me
according to a recent report some
teenagers believe
misinformation that the coronavirus
vaccine will one day turn people into
so-called zombies
it's the second dumbest thing teenagers
believe in after pulling out
[Laughter]
in honor of actress meryl streep's 72nd
birthday this week
fans changed new york city's 72nd street
subway station signed to say 72nd
street which is cool and all but she
asked for cash
the biden administration announced
support for a bill that would close the
gap between jail sentences for crack and
powder cocaine offenses
said people convicted of powder cocaine
offenses oh my god it's great i mean it
sucks but it's fair like it's totally
fair because if you think about it
there shouldn't be a difference at all
and finally the tv show sesame street
recently introduced a new family that
consists of
two gay dads and their daughter that
story again
bert and ernie now have a daughter and
that was the monologue
i really enjoyed it i'm glad but i'll
tell you what i didn't enjoy
the latest news about climate change
president biden was in europe last week
where he met with the leaders from the
european union
to discuss wait is that
it is i'm on it get me a chocolate
okay now that's the neighborhood ice
cream truck it only comes around a few
times a day and
they have the best ice cream so you
really don't want to miss it
now fortunately tarik is super fast so
i'm sure he'll have no problem catching
up to it
oh derek did you get it
oh you didn't get it was the truck gone
when you got there
i saw the truck he didn't see he didn't
see me
oh bummer i was really craving a cone so
was i
well that's all right we'll get it next
time moving on
president biden was in europe last week
[Music]
chocolate sprinkles
thank you okay look i know this might
seem
like a lot but this ice cream is good
it's like
the best you've ever had like ben and
jerry's without the b-minus puns
it is that good
oh tarek you didn't get it
yeah dude he saw me
he saw me running but when i got close
he floored it i'm sure it was just a
misunderstanding
no this was no accident
i could see his eyes in the rearview
mirror you saw me
he looked right through me and he smiled
and then he took off he wouldn't just
drive away he wants your money you don't
know what he wants
oh derek that's all right we'll have
another chance to get ice cream i don't
want ice cream anymore
really no i want it so bad i'm sorry
it's just
it just felt it felt very personal i'm
sure it wasn't
you're right and you know what we can
always just get some oreos from the
craft service table to satisfy our suite
we don't need ice cream
[Music]
okay now maybe this isn't my proudest
moment but
look at it from my perspective that ice
cream is
incredible now does this chase seem to
be having a profound effect on the
mental health of my friend tarek
perhaps i don't have to answer to you i
have to answer to anyone
i mean i like tarik
oh you kind of got it
that man is the devil you don't mean
that i do
satan lucifer the ales above what have
you
he is them and they are he what happened
i ran as fast as i could faster than
i've run before
but the truck didn't move
even as i drew close it stayed still
waiting
croaking its siren song into the mist i
approached the window
and he was there watching me with fire
in his eyes and ice cream into his veins
he knew my wants my desires my failures
my foibles
he knew all he saw all i asked for two
chocolate cones with sprinkles
and he pierced me with those eyes those
hideous
eyes and he said
we only have vanilla no yes
in that moment i knew i had come too far
i could not turn away i had to accept
this frosty and bargain
no yes but alas
i was punished for my weakness how were
you punished
some guy in line accidentally bumped me
and both the cones fell into the ground
no yes do you still want one
yeah me too thank you yeah
i had enough i'm watching my figure
get rounder i have my own youtube
channel now
yay be sure to subscribe for a lot of
show clips and a lot of digital
exclusives
and a lot of this but
[Music]